vous
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de point de vue nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir ce soir mathieu
souquières qui est très en forme qui
avait déjà commencé le débat d'ailleurs
avant le début du générique que vous
êtes consultant on est aussi expert
associé à la fondation jean jaurès ça
m'arrive
et vous avez conseillé certain nombre de
responsables politiques dont la ministre
maria belle connerie et bonsoir jérôme
sainte marie
vous êtes politologues sondeurs et créez
votre propre cabinet pôle inbox est
aussi essayiste et votre dernier livre
en attendant suivant qui est presque
prêt paraît-il bloc contre bloc la
dynamique du maquereau nisme aux
éditions du cerf
alors on va parler de politique c'est
l'une des conséquences du premier tour
des régionales c'est qu'il ya des
rapprochements entre les différentes
listes de gauche qui parfois fusionnent
comme c'est le cas en ile-de-france où
derrière julien bayou audrey pulvar et
clémentine autain ont concentré leurs
forces
regardez cette carte des régions de
france que nous vous avons concocté
elle montre qu' il ya cinq régions dans
lesquelles les quatre principales forces
de gauche ont fait liste commune
l'île de france j'en parlais à l'instant
mais aussi les hôtes france les pays de
la loire le centre val de loire et
auvergne rhône-alpes
d'où cette question toute simple jérôme
sainte marie
l'union de la gauche est de retour oui
enfin visiblement pas ce que c'est il ya
une tentative de la faire ça va être
intéressant en quelque sorte parce que
comme votre carte le montrer il ya
plusieurs formules en quelque sorte
qu'il veut en plusieurs nuances de rouge
ou de rose et donc c'est des uniformes
d'aspe un peu laboratoire en quelque
sorte pour voir ce qui marche ou six qui
ne marche pas ça peut avoir des
conséquences bien sûr sur la
présidentielle malgré le côté
extrêmement artificielle de l'exercice
puisque la gauche aussi est quand même
un peu impactée par la faiblesse de la
participation plus précisément c'est une
certaine gauche qui s'est mobilisé
l'animal dimension populaire de la
gauche ça existe encore et bien
forcément est sans doute restée chez
elle
donc il ya un petit côté un peu
artificielle dans cette expérience de
laboratoire c'est pas des conditions
parfaites
d'un point de vue scientifique mais
voilà avons effectivement
une formule d'union de la gauche c c
alors la question c'est est-ce que ça
n'est ce pas c'est purement tactique
mathieu soutien ou est ce que est ce que
ces gens ont réussi à se trouver des
choses en commun
les deux mon général et ça a toujours
été comme ça c'est à dire que la gauche
plurielle du temps de lionel jospin elle
avait un intérêt à s'allier mais elle
avait aussi précisément des intérêts en
commun des intérêts de fonds en commun
et il est toujours possible de d'établir
une plateforme programmatique commune
programme commun c'est encore plus dur
que la gauche plurielle
ça fait longtemps que ça existe et est
ce qui est vrai c'est que la gauche a
toujours dû en été en passer par une
union pour accéder au pouvoir
c'est sa faiblesse en réalité elle est
sous la vème république
depuis le début plus faible que la
droite et donc elle a besoin de s'unir
pour gagner ou en tout cas quand elle
n'est pas uni en général elle perd alors
là on voit qu'il ya effectivement
plusieurs formules que c'est à la carte
la carte de france dit bien que c'est à
la carte en fonction des régions en
fonction des spécificités locales
d'inimitié ou d'amitié locale
mais du coup on voit bien que par
rapport à la gauche plurielle à laquelle
je faisais référence à un instant on
recule puisque cette union de la gauche
elle ne fait plus consensus partout
alors on peut le dire comme le disait
jérôme que c'est finalement du
pragmatisme ça permet de regarder au gré
des échelles locales ce qui fonctionne
le mieux ce qui paraît le plus efficace
je crains malheureusement d'ailleurs
qu'on puisse pas en tirer règle générale
l'union de la gauche ne se fait dans les
hauts de france
elle se termine avec un score assez
faible elle ne s'est pas fait on ils
devront soit 6 10 retour dans les eaux
de france elle s'est fait d'être ouvert
une seule liste j'aurais dû être plus
précis exactement en ile de france elle
ne s'est pas faite au premier tour elle
se fait dans l'antre de tours et on
verra si cela permet d'enclencher une
dynamique d'entre deux tours qui lui
permet puisque la politique encore une
fois ça n'est pas de l'arithmétique qui
lui permet à la fin de faire davantage
que les scores additionnés de ces de ses
candidats désuni et parfois il y en a
plus du tout comme comme en provence
alpes côte d'azur ou
la gauche s'est fait hara-kiri comme la
dernière fois commandé du oui juste un
point là dessus on s'étendra peut-être
un peu sur europe écologie les verts
dans ce scrutin
europe ecologie les verts a bien marché
aux européennes de 2019 a même encore
mieux marché aux municipales de 2020 en
gagnant quelques grandes villes
je crains que ce scrutin quand même même
si encore une fois son score global
n'est pas catastrophique
je crains quand même que ce scrutin ne
soit pas très bon pour ramper cologie
les verts là où europe écologie les
verts précisément embarque comme
locomotive de l'union de la gauche dans
les hauts de france
le score est assez faible il est même il
est même très faible objectivement et en
paca puisque vous faites référence à
paca on aura connu pendant quelques
jours effectivement cette tête de liste
qui aura dû attendre quelques heures
tragiquement pour renoncer alors même
qu'il faisait peu de doute que à la fin
ils auraient à canet c'est un peu triste
en réalité que d'avoir donné ce
spectacle là on pas car je vous redonne
à parle tout de suite saint jérôme et
avant je voudrais la donner à nos
internautes comme parade comme tous les
jours et pas comme par hasard vous
donner votre point de vue vous aussi on
vous a posé la question selon-vous
l'union de la gauche est elle de retour
avec ces régionales et ben vous êtes
assez sceptique voire même très
sceptique puisque 84% d'entre vous
interroger sur twitter considère que non
voici un ou deux points de vue
aux régionales elle a pratiquement
toujours existé nous dire y dh alors
qu'aux présidentielles où les querelles
d'ego entre en compte et où les
différences idéologiques en plus de
poids la gauche est mal parti et puis va
dingue
elle est peut-être de retour mais bon si
elle fait 20% je ne vois pas en quoi
c'est un événement oui alors en fait
j'ai me faut du temps pour comprendre
les questions j'ai vu compris la vôtre
il faut revenir quand même à ce que
c'est que l'union de la gauche l'union
de la gauche c'est pas dans l'histoire
politique française
c'est dans le vocabulaire politique
également c'est pas seulement le fait de
une alliance de second tour
ça c'est pas l'union de la gauche c'est
la gauche comme c'est la droite
être de gauche c'est au fond de choisir
l'autre candidat à gauche qui sera
qualifié au second tour celle aussi le
sien ne l'a pas été c'est une question
de discipline puisque de juin l'union de
la gauche c'est un pas que ça existait
donc au tournant des années 70
et bien c'est effectivement une ce
programme commun en réalité dire que
c'est effectivement des forces
clairement séparés qu'ils choisissent
parfois dès le premier tour
c'était le cas en 65 pour la
présidentielle c'était le cas également
en 74 d'ailleurs et donc qu'ils
choisissent effectivement là le parti
communiste qui choisissait de s'effacer
derrière un candidat de gauche et en 74
avec un programme commun en bus là
c'était vraiment l'union de la gauche
qui était donc structuré et ça pouvait
fonctionner pourquoi et c'est pour ça
qu'elle doit être la différence est
radical par rapport à aujourd'hui c'est
qu'à l'époque ya eu des grandes forces
de gauche qui étaient qu avait quand
même des cultures et d une sociologie
différentes
grosso modo on avait le parti communiste
qui a amené certains syndicats comme la
cgt et bonne partie comme du monde
ouvrier
le parti socialiste a mené lui aussi les
syndicats mais plutôt vous savez la
fédération d'éducation nationale la cfdt
et avait une plutôt d'une fonction du
public il certains étaient pro
atlantistes d'autres très pro soviétique
c'était vraiment d'effort différentes
qui avait choisi de faire un effort
électoraliste important avec cette union
de la gauche
là c'est un peu une parodie parce que
vous comprenez je prends l'île de france
par exemple vous avez trois forces qui
ont des cultures politiques différentes
relativement mais audrey pulvar
clémentine autain et c'est julien
bayou c'est quand même des gens qui se
ressemblent étonnamment qui de leur
entourage c'est à peu près la même
culture c'est un peu ce que
j'appellerais un peu la gauche
universitaire si vous voulez donc c'est
pas des forces très très différentes
ils ont été séparés parce que les
appareils étaient pas les mêmes mais
c'est vrai qu' à la fois une assez
grande convergence mais cette
convergence révèle en fait une grande
faiblesse c'est que ça ne concerne plus
que quelques milieux sociaux à ses parts
à la recette une convergence de
personnes vous le disiez mais est-ce que
sur le fond ces différents partis sont
si proches que ça gamin qui n'y croient
pas et qui pensent que cette alliance
est contre nature c'est manuel valls
écouter l'ancien premier ministre
socialiste il était hier chez nos
confrères de lci
alors vous voyez apparaître à l'écran
manuel valls qui explique pourquoi
est-ce qu à son avis cette alliance en
ile de france est mauvaise au milieu
mon confrère d'argus rangement et à
droite julien bayou qui est justement la
tête de liste écologiste de cette liste
unique
je m'autorise aussi à penser que
l'alliance avec jean luc mélenchon et
avec ses amis est une faute politique et
morale je le dis tranquillement sans
anathème sans insultes mais s'allier
avec ceux qui font preuve d'ambiguïté
dans soutien aux policiers sur la
question de la laïcité
sur la question de la lutte contre
l'islamisme sur la question de la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme
sur tous ces sujets qui sont au coeur du
débat identitaire ou du débat
républicain s'est allié avec cette
gauche là et d'une foule alors dernier
mot
une faute politique mathieu soutient
manuel valls a de la suite dans les
idées il a toujours affirmé qu'ils
avaient ces deux gauches
irréconciliables qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
là il s'est peut-être un peu trop
éloigné de la politique nationale il est
parti à barcelone quelques temps et du
coup il ya des choses que vous échapper
tout juste vraiment je vois pas en quoi
je crois qu'il parlait précisément en
plus de l'alliance en ile de france et
je vois pas en quoi
clémentine autain par exemple est
suspecte d'antisémitisme ou dre porteuse
d'un d'identité je précise même les
choses en fait on parle de personnalités
politiques dont luc mélenchon était dans
le gouvernement de lionel jospin à
l'époque où manuel valls était le
conseiller de lionel jospin à dire
l'argent et et sociale est ce qu'on peut
dire les choses ont changé certes mais
j'ai du mal à comprendre qu'un ancien
allié sûr devenu quelqu'un d'absolument
infréquentable au point que sa
fréquentation constitue une faute morale
et politique
je vais encore une fois on peut quand
même faire preuve d'un minimum de d'un
minimum de nuances je précise même que
clémentine autain par exemple s'il
s'agit d'elle en l'occurrence a été
adjointe apparenté communiste au maire
de paris pendant un mandat bertrand
delanoë jeu tout ça me paraissait
extrêmement compatible n'y avait rien
rien dire est considérable donc j'ai
l'impression que on surjoue en
l'occurrence des désaccords qui
n'existent pas fondamentalement et je
dis même que clémentine autain a été des
trois candidats en ile de france la
première à dire il nous faudra faire
l'alliance
il nous faudra précisément nous
réconcilier et c'est notre seule façon
de battre potentiellement valérie
pécresse donc je vois défend pas
spécialement clémentine autain mais je
trouve que la charge de manuel valls est
un tout petit peu à côté de la plaque
rexona veut ça n'a pas de sens tout à
fait entre nous de faire de manuel valls
seul arbitre des élégances ago plus nord
jeudi reflets c'est ce qu'on appelle sur
internet un troll vous savez il ya là
pour le premier ministre
alors c'est d'être il a failli être le
candidat de son pour allegro
présidentielle mais il a perdu la
primaire il a fait d'assez loin
il a fait droit et par ailleurs non mais
c'est un troll cyr qui lancent des
invectives qui allaitent sont à la
limite de la diffamation en réalité
c'est repris par les autres camps qui
sont ravis de voir que ça va mettre de
l'ambiance à gauche c'est toujours le
même je peux pas rentrer je pas prononcé
certains mots mais c'est toujours le
même type d'accusation c'est vraiment à
la fois assez grave mais qui deviennent
dérisoires à force d'être
énoncé à tout sujet est toujours sûr
mais sur le fond même propos alors
effectivement ça peu de choses à voir
avec tarik ou régional mais ont cogné
deux cultures de gaulle différentes
entre la culture de d'une gauche
républicaine et d'une gauche plus tenté
par le sepa une vision communautaire de
la société française ça ça existe quand
même c'est par manuel valls qui l'a
inventé je veux pas rentrer sur ce
terrain là parce qu'en plus sur les
talons de choses à dire ce manuel valls
mais c'est qu'on ne sait pas exactement
si l'émetteur est le mieux placé pour
dénoncer ce qui le les autres mais c'est
un problème c'est un autre problème
oui donc se faire souffrir d'autres fois
bref c'est assez curieux et non
évidemment c'est un des clivages mais il
ya un clivage sérieux sur sept qui sont
deux républiques et d'universalisme ça
existe c'est de l'ayrolle sont pas
exactement à mon avis ceux de la
répartie de la manière dont manuel valls
prétend qu'ils le sont mais pourquoi pas
mais vous avez des clivages beaucoup
plus sérieux vous avez très nombreux
clivages sur bastia un truc un peu comme
ça ok tout à fait neutre sur l'europe
sur l'europe il ya un vrai clivage une
une gauche qui a voté oui une gauche qui
a voté non ça c'est précis c'est clair
mais il ya toujours eu des clivages
encore une fois à l'époque d'union de la
gauche et du problème comment les des
gens c'était vrai mais en pleine guerre
froide ça se bat et enfin il ya la
guerre froide qui était chaud dans ce
parc à quelques théâtres etc
les gens étaient favorables à l'urss
d'autres voulaient rester dans l'otan
cela qu'on qui ont triomphé
c'était pas rien si vous voulez il y
avait des trucs plein de sujets sur
lequel c'est différent sauf qu'il y
avait le sentiment qu'il y avait à
comment dirais-je que y avait ni à une
perspective de victoire donc ça ça
permet aussi l'arrivée à des compromis
et puis qui avait aussi derrière des
forces sociales qui poussait dans le
même sens là aujourd'hui les forces
sociales pousse beaucoup moins on va
dire est ce qui fait qu on est dans
l'idéologie et les propos que tient
manuel valls et ses amis c'est
véritablement quelques amis qu'il a
désormais en tout cas dans son camp à
temps son ancien camp ce qu'on sait plus
où il va parce que on sait si on s'amuse
en plus ça veut jouer par à parler de la
politique par capillarité machin a eu
quelques uns de ses proches qui a
participé à tel meeting à ce moment là
on regarde laquelle meeting à participer
manuel valls à barcelone j'ai rien j'ai
rien contre vox est une formation à la
droite du parti populaire et donc tous
les héritiers du franquisme
j'ai rien à verger président le droit
d'être là et c'est mes petits il donne
des leçons à la gauche il va participer
à des meetings avec vox et après alors
qu'il a écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
un est impardonnable qui s'affiche comme
un grand partisan de la république
espagnole en 36
merci ça le parcours politique le
personnel et manuel valls 3 au coeur de
cette émission on va peut-être
changer de sujet encore que voilà une
remarque très intéressante darcos guy
qui nous dit si on trouve normal
l'alliance gauche ultra gauche pourquoi
rejeter la nuance droite extrême droite
et c'est vrai que valérie pécresse a
relevé ce point en dix ans mais le les
partis extrêmes à quand ils sont à
gauche c'est formidable on a le droit de
faire tout ce qu'on veut
alors qu'à droite c'est indigne vous
comprenez ce deux poids deux mesures
parce que je me permets avant de vous
répondre juste d' insister sur un point
sépare les noms mais sur les gauches
irréconciliables
c'est effectivement c'est quand même le
sujet c'est surtout manuel valls qui les
voit irréconciliables car si on regarde
les enquêtes les différents courants de
la gauche aujourd'hui sont favorables
ultra majoritairement à une union de la
gauche donc les sympathisants de gauche
je ne vois pas en quoi il y aurait des
sujets qu'il soit irréconciliables et
comme le disait jérôme sainte-marie tout
à l'heure il y a toujours eu de fortes
disparités à gauche de fortes
différences des points de clivage
mais les points de clivage qui ont su
historique non se surmonter car
l'intérêt stratégique à un instant t
c'est de savoir définir une plateforme
commune alors ok et sur le deux poids
deux mesures alors sur le deux poids
deux mesures à la même chose alors je
dis c'est pas la même chose
l'extrême droite s'est historiquement
situés en marge du champ républicain
l'extrême droite a été historiquement et
demi du camp républicain
elle a jusqu'à il ya peu en tout cas
c'était tout à fait vrai du temps de
l'open vers elle a continué à afficher
des positions qui la mettait hors du
champ républicain
manuel valls parle donc des ambiguïtés
en matière d'antisémitisme de je sais
pas qui de thé menti noté julien bayou
etc soyons sérieux
jean marie le pen il y à peu ne jouait
quasiment pas d'ambiguïté en matière
d'antisémitisme et il se trouve tout de
même que même si jean marie le pen a été
exclu de son parti même si marine le pen
a en termes de posture adoptée
effectivement une attitude différente et
des propos différents
la fondation jean jaurès que je
représente ici a produit une note il ya
quelques temps où ils sont
sans aller faire beaucoup d'archéologie
juste déterrer des profils de candidats
aux régionales et on voit bien qu'il y a
des dizaines et des dizaines de
candidats aux régionales sur les listes
front national qui se sont fait à août
et sur des déclarations antisémites des
dérapages racistes etc
donc je ne dis pas que
la totalité de l'appareil frontiste est
comme ça je ne dis pas que la totalité
des électeurs ou des sympathisants du
front national sont des gens racistes ou
antisémites jeudi qu ça reste un parti à
part avec un noyau d'extrémistes de
droite qui sont effectivement en marge
du champ républicain ce qu'on ne
retrouve pas pardon mais au sein de la
france insoumise
c'est une toute petite chose c'est que
petit je crois que votre question la
remettre en cause celle là aussi parce
que comment dirais-je ya un point commun
c'est quand on appelle extrême gauche
quelque chose qui n'est plus le sien
gauche la france insomnies ce n'est pas
à l'extrême gauche
ils n'ont pas un programme marxiste
léniniste lutte ouvrière c'est l'extrême
gauche il propose un changement de
régime
c'est leur droit et se baisser
clairement l'accent gauche la france un
film en 2d gauche radicale d'ailleurs on
refuse l'étiquette des caniveaux jette
son gauche le front national n'est pas
l'extrême droite qui ne propose pas un
changement de régime
il suivait toutes les règles proposées
et c'est encore une fois on peut
parfaitement être en désaccord total
avec ce que dit la france a soumises ou
leur assemblée nationale mais on peut
pas les qualifier d'extrême gauche avec
son droite en toute rigueur et bien au
fond de la salle reste le seul parti
encore une fois peut compter sur ses
listes les anciens compères pablo et
rafa jean thissen projet une autre un
autre sujet à vous proposer je vous
propose que nous nous y passions